وانضم الينا من ايديمان محمود شكر موفد
العربيه اهلا بك يا محمود محمود بدايه
التقرير الوارده من تركيا تشير الى انه
عمليات البحث عن ناجين توقفت في لولي في
تركيا ليلا بسبب نقص فرق الانقاذ هل هذه
المعلومات دقيقه وما السبب
بدايه اسمح لي ان اطبق السؤال على هذا
الواقع والواقع اطبقها على الجوله والجوله
التي قمنا بها منذ حوالي الساعتين في كافه
ارجاء المدينه نحن الان في اهم الشوارع
الرئيسيه لمدينه ايدمن لم يسجل لدينا او
لم نلاحظ ولم نصادف ان هنالك ورشه او
مجموعه من المتطوعين او الجرافات تعمل في
المدينه على عكس ما كان عليه في الايام
الماضيه استطيع القول انه لربما انه توجد
في هذه المدينه في هذه الليله المئات من
الجرافات وايضا الحفارات والالات الثقيله
ولكنها اطفات محركاتها وهذا الاطفاء مرده
الى عده عوامل اهمه الا اننا نتحدث ونحن
معك الان على الهواء مباشره بعد اليوم
الحادي عشر على وقوع الكارثه مما يعني ان
الوصول الى
احياء تحت الارقاد هو اصبح
جمل ضعيف جدا فضلا عن ذلك الى ان عمليات
البحث او عمليات المسح ما بين البحث
والمسحي التي قامت بها الفرق وتحديدا التي
تمتلك الاجهزه ان كانت الاستشعار عن بعد
لاجسام حراريه او ايضا حركه الصوت او ايضا
ما يسمى بعمليات
الصوت والتصوير هذه الالات المحدثه هي لم
تدلل في مكان ما على حركه في كل هذه
البنايه
بعض الانباء تشير الى انه الكثير من فرق
الانقاذ غادرت خصوصا الاجنبيه تركيا وعادت
الى بلدانها مع اقتراب انقضاء اليوم
العاشر على هذه الكارثه
البرتغال الدولي الذي
الامم المتحده هو ينص على عمليه الاستعجال
الطارئ لهذه الفرق بمعنى كل فرقه حصلت على
سبعه ايام يحق لها ان تبدا بعمليه
المغادره وهذا صحيح بالفعل نحن كنا على
الهواء مباشره منذ ثلاث ساعات مع الفريق
السوداني الفريق الجزائري جزء الفريق
التونسي اليوم صباحا جزء من الفريق
البريطاني كل من هو متخصص بعمليات الاغاثه
السريعه
للحصول او للوصول الى ناجين على قاعده ان
تكون بطريقه
بالطريقه العاجله هم جاؤوا الى هنا ولكن
بما انه دخلنا الان في الروتين لعمليات
الرفع الانقاض والوصول ايضا الى الناجين
هذه الفرق بدات بالانسحاب في حين بالتوازي
معك انه في بعض المدن والمناطق لا يزال
الوصول الى احياء تحت الركام قائم وربما
يسجل لدينا في اليوم مع عمليه ذلك
خلال الايام الماضيه سؤال الاخير انه ايضا
هناك يعني انباء بانه
الحكومه التركيه قررت ربما هدم
المباني في بعض المدن بشكل كامل واعاده
بناءها اذا يمان واحده من اكثر المناطق
تضررا وربما سكانها غادروا المباني هل بدا
هناك تقييم
لهذه المباني صلاحيتها وما المتوقع حدوثه
خلال الفتره القادمه
التقييم هو قائم على هو قائم هو يحصل
عمليات الاجتماعات المكثفه ان كانت في
المحافظه مع الماء مع الوالي ومع القياده
العسكريه والقياده الميدانيه من مهندسين
وبلديه وهذا ايضا ما التقينا به عصر هذا
اليوم ولكن نحن بالتوازي كنا نراقب هل
بدات عجله هذه العمليات يعني هل اعطيت
الصفر عمليه الصفر لانتاقلاق عمليه رفع
الانقاذ بسرعه والبدء بعمليه انزال
الامنيه المتصدعه حتى هذه الساعه في اليوم
العاشر اتمكن من القول ان عمليه رفع
الارقاد التي هي بوتيره يمكن ان نراقبها
او ان ننقلها ان نجد مدينه باكملها كالتي
نحن فيها نستيقظ غدا او بعد غد ترى المئات
من الشاحنات التي تنقل الركام والرتميات
والحديد هذه حتى الساعه لم تحصل يظهر ان
هنالك بعض الاجراءات باتجاهها شكرا جزيلا
موفد العربيه محمود شكر كنت معنا مباشره
من اليمن